I love this girl
so good
I can't believe I can't do that anymore
I could do that Courtney Cox takes a
stab at this dance routine
but it doesn't quite go as planned
[Music]
the video went viral on Instagram last
year but Courtney's now spreading the
joy of her pain by re-sharing it on Tick
Tock she's become a social media star
look at these tinsy girls so cute
I want to do that what
[Music]
even having her longtime boyfriend
Johnny McDade and famous friends like Ed
Sheeran step in to make cameos
[Music]
but the friends actress solidified her
star power long before social media
Decades of hard work now cemented in
stone on the Hollywood Walk of Fame I
mean you are cemented in Hollywood
history how does it feel
s good
Gail weather's reporting for dirty still
girls right and she is
safe to say Court continues to be a
scene stealer on the big screen the
small screen and the phone screen
[Music]